hey guys I'm Dave and this is the
GameSpot news update
now the wasteland of Boston is the
safest place for a lone wanderer but to
keep your game safe secure make sure
you're aware of this potentially game
breaking fallout 4 glitch several users
have reported a serious game breaking
bugging Bethesda's open-world
role-playing game Fallout 4 as detailed
on the Bethesda forums the plug in
question concerns a settlement quest
which requires players to head to miss
ignore Plaza it seems to appear once you
have passed a certain point the story
reported as meeting the character
Valentine if you go back to an earlier
save with the bug you'll probably find
that you don't crash there so it happens
at some point later crash seems to
happen because the area changes over the
course of the story there is a console
command that resets the area although
doing so could cause other problems with
your game it is fairly game breaking as
the main story quests go through the
area making the game impossible to
complete if you have the bug and do not
use console commands the bug is
reportedly affected users on the ps4 the
Xbox one as well as PC versions while
there have been numerous reports of
glitches in the game surfacing online
not many of them have been as game
breaking in fact some players have used
them to their advantage hopefully a
patch will be released soon to fix this
bug as well as some of the others that
plagued the wastes have you encountered
this game breaking bugs in fallout 4 let
us know in the comments below or you can
find me on twitter at a regular Dave if
you want to see some more fallout
content make sure you check out our
fallout 4 show but the last episode we
listed through five new things that make
fallout 4 great and for everything else
gaming related keep you tuned in to
GameSpot calm
you